listen I don't have anything to do with
this so can we have I'm not doing
nothing
don't touch me I'm so tired of being
Twisted by you all of them I'm sorry
okay well I don't want to be touched I
didn't do nothing an Alabama man's
hysterical response is caught on body
camera video after he's arrested in
Northern Florida the disturbing video
was taken just hours before the suspect
was killed in a hit and run crash take
me to jail or let me go on June 28th
Panama City Beach police officers
arrested 27-year-old Derek Burnett of
Dothan Alabama after a tow truck driver
reported Burnett punched him
[Music]
start loading up this car doing his own
thing next thing you know the dude
smacks the bed at the truck he's like
hey don't touch my truck so the guy got
up like got up in his face
so he said I didn't hit him
officials quickly note aspects of
Burnett's story didn't make sense
no he said he rode a motorcycle here
because he claimed that they towed his
motorcycle and they they didn't tow any
motorcycles
and he said oh yes because my dad took
it home
but he's all over the place with some of
his story though so
but when First Responders speak with
Burnett he doubles down on his story
saying multiple times he did not attack
the man driving the tow truck
hit me
when he's put in the back of a squad car
body camera video captures brunette
purposely slam his head into the side of
a vehicle
without me man
if you don't think I'm up I've been a
courage I'm gonna catch a real family
you don't take these out I promise you I
will make it worth my wow
and when I get on you cut
what are you doing take me to jail we're
trying but now close the door and take
me after he hits his head Burnett is
then covered in blood
ah you do nothing man I don't know
probate family probation nine and a half
years
nine and a half years to get away from
y'all this ain't wrongfully attacked me
they called y'all
bro
what's going on
I ain't do nothing man
calm down
during this time Burnett alleges First
Responders knowingly brutalized him
I didn't do nothing man you ain't gonna
calm down you're gonna stay just like
this
we'll get your offices are done to me
just give me to calm down
dude
you expect me to calm down I've been
brutalized by police
y'all gonna let me go at the end of this
and we all do is every one of your my
Grandma has a party is coming for
everybody
and I ain't got nothing that meant to be
in there Cooks
in a seemingly hysterical State Burnett
says he's being detained for no reason
and later spits on officers okay look at
me
I just got here if I done anything to
you you have yeah
the one that detains you boss
take a deep breath no yes take me to
jail I'll get these income we're waiting
on paramedics they're on the way
entertainment stuff
oh
God
wait dude you just wait
get yourself a man you wait
I'm done I promise you I'm done y'all
please let me sit up please I'm gonna
calm down I am I said I'm done so I am
doing I promise you on my three kids
life I am doing just let me sit up take
me to jail please
that's all imagine let me sit up take me
to jail man
come on be going to jail in a minute
you want to go back the same way I want
to go to jail
no we're not
sure
I'll lay down you want me to lay down
sit just like you are I lay down on my
back cause I'm done
you took four offices when taken to EMS
responders Burnett again spits and
refuses their help
I don't want to I don't know because if
we have the van on the way for him wait
I think they just called to make sure
that this is in like debilitating
injuries or anything like that
when he's placed in back of a transport
van Burnett continues to act out and
purposely bangs his head again
[Music]
I'll admit I've been the one to attack
but I didn't do nothing okay stop
stop
foreign
[Music]
what you gonna do when you let go I'll
still do the same thing
y'all motherfuckers are abuse yourself
y'all honestly just just sit back and
think about what you doing right now
just if I can think what you doing right
now are you gonna stop banging your head
no I'm not no I'm not
nope
you're in a steel cage I almost bust my
head wow
let me go
because I'm being wrongfully detained
close that doors
non-essential injuries to me because it
should have never been done in the first
place everyone is injuries
and you pay for that in court you pay
for that information I know my rights
coach
so we can close the door
I always I can't stand up when I get
there
we're trying to get this over with but
we can't win because I've been put in
the back of a police cars now for no
Burnett was taken to jail where he was
later released after signing a notice
saying he would soon appear in court two
days later his body was found on the
side of the road officials determined he
died in a hit and run crash that
happened just hours after he left the
jail so far no one has been arrested in
relation to that crash reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie